hey reject nation Greg Albie here and
I'm John Rosa Parra from patreon our
Lady Stark of the channel has requested
this special video from watchmojo.com
but lists video that's bound to have
said many of people mystical top-ten
Marvel Cinematic Universe movies
published after infinity war so expect
to see that on this list but hey before
we do that gotta give a shout out to
today's video sponsor you might have
seen on Collider videos before and many
other YouTube channels the app game
Vikings
World clans people that's right ladies
and gentlemen if you've ever had dreams
of conquering the world we're in a
spikey helmet and bathing in the blood
of your enemies this is the game for you
war of clans echoes the rpgs and
strategy based games of the 90s and
2000's and the app has just undergone a
massive update complete with new
kingdoms shamans and a whole lot more
honestly when it comes to app games
Viking stands out with its
high-definition 3d graphics fluid
gameplay and a variety of play styles to
choose from erect an impenetrable
fortress for you and your clan or rally
some friends together and go on a
pillaging spree toward world domination
and for those of you who like a good
challenge you can even hop online and do
battle with millions of players in one
of war of clans massive online battle
events so head on down to that
description box there click our special
link to download the app and get started
today when you use our link you'll get
an extra 200 gold and a protection
shield on us click our link not Ken naps
obviously and we WatchMojo let's see if
we agree with your lists Thor the dark
world better be number one oh yeah and
The Incredible Hulk Joe what a decade
it's be welcome to watchmojo.com and
today we're counting down our picks for
the top 10 MCU movies
or has really become a man-whore we
publish new content every day so be sure
to subscribe to our channel and ring the
ballot I've notified about videos for
this list we're looking back at 10 years
worth of Marvel Cinematic Universe
movies and deciding which 10 are our
favorites okay a camera 10 Doctor
Strange ok the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is no stranger to fantasy but the first
cinematic appearance of the master of
the mystic arts kick things up a notch
or two
when brilliant neurosurgeon dr. Steven
strange as his hands mangled in a brutal
car wreck his search for a treatment
leads him down a pretty unexpected path
one that ends with him as Earth's newest
magical protector with psychedelic
visuals and epic fight scenes that
combines spell-casting and martial arts
this is definitely one of the most
visually dazzling entries in the MCU and
that's saying something
thankfully yes Adobe I have Okimoto to
turn back time and watch it again
[Music]
number 9 thor ragnarok Neal it's pretty
high up here on this it's bold
number 9 let's be honest the first few
entries of Thor weren't the most
exciting films the MCU had to offer but
the third installment changed that in a
big way combining director Tycho ITT's
trademark humor with a pessimistic
aesthetic in addition to familiar faces
like Thor Loki and Heimdall the film
also introduces a whole whack of new
characters and decided to see any of
them returned for more movies come on
Marvel give us that Korg spin-off you
know you want to it was cool I'm kind of
like the leader in year number 80 war -
hi for fans hello I mean
that's gonna upset me feel it already
bringing together practically all of its
major characters for an epic
confrontation with the mad Titan himself
Pano's once again Joe and Anthony Russo
pull off a giant crossover event that
feels like a comic book come to life
but as Josh Brolin's Thanos that simply
steals the show there's more to Thanos
than meets the eye and while seeing this
enormous cast of characters come
together as something fans have been
eagerly waiting for they couldn't
possibly have anticipated what infinity
war ultimately delivers number seven
spider-man homecoming you two appear
alongside the other Marvel heroes and
her prayers were finally answered in a
big way after appearing in Captain
America Civil War the webhead swung into
his first solo MCU adventure and the
result was everything we wanted it comes
in footage firemen he got paid ten
million dollars of every week new Spidey
and Tom Hollands will say nothing of the
incredible supporting cast and really
who would have ever thought that the
vulture would turn out to be a great and
memorable villain the vulture we
wouldn't have called that one oh man
Marvel fans are so upset with this list
I can feel it feel it 6 Black Panther
a lot of recent horrible in the back cap
new comer to the MCU this is I've as
cinematic solo outing quickly became one
of the most beloved and successful comic
book movies ever not just in the MCU and
when you watch it it's not hard to see
why Ryan Coogler film is a brilliant and
visually breathtaking offering that
perfectly bounces superhero action with
powerful and relevant themes and that's
not even getting into Michael B Jordans
performance as kill monger a villain who
people are already calling one of the
best in the history of the MCU my
personal dream will conduct forever
Lokhande forever number five guardians
of the galaxy that's my top 5 when
Marvel announced that this practically
unknown superhero team which includes
the talking raccoon and is buddy this is
probably gone off the deep end but
imagine our surprise when the end
product wasn't just a fantastic movie
but one of the most fun engaging MCU
films to date and one of the most
emotionally engaging comic-book movies
ever made on top of introducing
characters who since I rocketed in
popularity going from little-known to
household names almost damn bautista got
even tougher yeah
yeah me number four
Captain America the Winter Soldier a
damn good spy thriller Captain America's
second adventure came out with the gate
running literally whenever the Hydra
orchestrated conspiracy within the ranks
of shield he and the Black Widow go
rogue to stop the sinister Hydra before
they can unleash a fleet of helicarriers
on an unsuspecting public I know many
people who say this is the number one
fleurs the true identity of the Winter
Soldier top assassin well it's common
for middle films in a trilogy to be the
weakest in the series the second Captain
America film breaks that trend into
gloriously badass bashes the one the
only the movie that started it all the
first film in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is still one of the very best
that's great film came out of nowhere
and took the world by storm he's gotta
bring that era back home
taking a relatively unknown hero and
turning him into one of the most
recognizable characters in pop culture
let's face it this is not the worst
thing you've got me doing of course none
of this would have been possible without
Robert Downey jr. stepping into the
boots of a role that reignited his
career and the ever reliable they got
Pam for 500,000 to do Siri
MCU films have gotten bigger the very
rarely better
number 2 the Avengers the Avengers
that's what we call ourselves
when 7s appearance at the end of Ironman
the countdown officially began to a film
that comic book fans have been dreaming
up for decades over the next several
years
Marvel carefully set the stage for the
biggest superhero epic the world had
that's amazing it surpassed even our
wildest xfinity - gather Captain America
Iron Man Thor the Hulk and numerous
other characters from their extensive
roster of heroes
but instead they made comic book movie
history with a film that remains one of
their absolute best what's their number
one gonna be Civil War where we reveal
our cap and use your arm dumb rule
honorable mentions what are you doing
like it's gonna be Civil War honorable
mentions all the other Avengers age of
Ultron is gonna be number one yeah
Captain America Civil War trying to keep
you from turning the Avengers apart did
that when you say want to know the one
thing harder than making a great middle
film in a trilogy making the third film
- absolute best of them all Captain
America's third adventure sees the
Avengers torn apart when legislation is
introduced that would place them under
director I can understand this being
number one on someone's list enigmatic
Winter Soldier only makes it worse
there's no other film we could think of
like a famous a superhero action serious
themes impaired with you drama see that
Marvel hit this one out of the park is
an understatement do you agree with our
picks check out these other great clips
from watch mojo and subscribe for new
videos yeah I mean I would have put age
of Ultron a number 3 Incredible Hulk and
number 2 dark world you know easily
before dark world
oh yes that what so I remember for yes
we'd react to these those videos we'll
talk about each individual film and our
thoughts on it this is a list that's
just doomed to upset people cuz no one's
gonna have the same list no one's in
have the same list for a franchise that
is the Marvel Cinematic Universe an
entire studio that's dedicated to one
franchise that has franchises when it's
one massive franchise it's like
impossible to make a list that will
ultimately satisfy but there are numbers
here where I'm like oh you're definitely
gonna get crap for putting them at like
number eight vanity war at eight that
skyrocketed to the top five for many of
people and after watching it a third
time I would definitely say it's in my
top five it functions on two levels I
feel like for a lot of people it'll
probably resemble your top ten but the
order will probably be wild yeah exactly
and on the one hand like I kind of get
what they're going for because you know
I mean just just in the timeline of life
we put a lot of the more recent downs at
the back half because they haven't had
the benefit of time so much infinity
Wars only been out for two weeks so I
understand why they might not have put
it yeah sure sure but at the same time
you bring up a really good point which
is like it's already distinguished
itself as one of their most distinct
gutsy movie and this is a film that
we're still talking about and people are
gonna be theorizing and coming up with
analysis on it until the next one comes
out
the next two vendors movie you know yeah
there's the other part of this is like
where all these films fit together and
the idea that likes certain of them you
have to have seen before some of the
other ones will even make yeah they
needed like a disclaimer as to why they
were putting that at number eight I mean
I think they were honing in on the fact
that it's fan OSes movie that sounded
like what this really calm gentleman was
so weird to see all this video for an
MCU Thaegan to have like just this
really calm voice it is the most
exciting film in the MCU they really
knocked it out of the park
okay that was to keep people's nerd rage
down yeah I agree with your point that
this is arguably the ten films you would
most likely hear about there are some
where I'm like uh I mean for my personal
taste I get these lists are subjective
that's why I was saying during it oh my
god there's one guy who's sometimes
these channels do that where they'll
have one dude just put this video
together and just his opinions on it
it's not a team of people working on
this list what I'm thinking this is a
video that requires a team of people to
really come together
oh yeah and ultimately determine cuz
this seems like a very personal
subjective list to me it doesn't seem
like they really did like a whole team
work Doctor Strange at number 10
actually makes a lot of sense to me
because it's not the best told movie but
they had good points about it being one
of the most visually bold films they've
done Oh
weirdest ones they've done it's kind of
a risk to do that with with the movies
that were especially at this point where
there was a pretty well known formula
and this movie follows that formula
essentially I don't disagree with that
or Ragnarok I can even kind of see that
because it's so much of a whimsical
comedy yeah it's so much fun and there
are people who weren't excited about
that direction for Thor and even so I
mean it does kind of feed directly into
infinity war but it is yeah just a
lighter adventure I feel like on a lot
of these lists the lighter films are
reserved for the later spot yeah
spider-man homecoming I honestly would
have put a number nine or eight you know
like I really love Tom Holland in that
movie and I think there's a lot of fun
to be had in that film I've seen it a
like two or three times at this point
the last time I watched them I realized
I don't I love Tom Hall and I love
spider-man but I don't really love the
film as a whole this is my personal
opinion this is videos even talking
about this video is bound to get you in
trouble
Black Panther I'm like that that should
be in the top five some people might
call it overhyped whatever in my
personal opinion that is one of the best
standalone Marvel films easily and I
mean it's one of the ones that has the
most on its mind it's one of the ones
that has you know a very culturally
relevant edge on it to like civil war
does as well in a totally different way
but you know they they bothered to
breach and discuss bigger things than
just you know these are the 10 films
that would be on my list there's no
doubt about that these are the 10 MCU
films that would be there I feel like
you leave like maybe a small margin of
error for wildcards because you know
somebody's favorite is done out there
somewhere you know civil war is not my
favorite why top 5 would have to be
Avengers 1 Iron Man Black Panther Civil
War infinity war and my top 5 I didn't
specify them in a specific order I'd
have to think about that I'm just
telling you what I'll get crap for like
not putting Winter Soldier in the top 5
I know I would what her soldiers is such
a serious yeah well some people love
that for my personal taste I'm like well
and Civil War broke ground in terms of
like it's still at least to me it was
still a Captain America movie even
though you had so many other characters
and it took on the format of what we're
doing yeah I have the superhero
discussion that BBS didn't you know
which we yeah what are the legalities
and the rules what are the ethics of
this that's enough caliber for me to
look that pretty high on the list in
that regard I can see maybe parts of
this it's like yeah like a spider-man or
a Ragnarok would end up lower on the
list or or even a doctor Doctor Strange
if not in my top 5 would be like number
6 or something
I might even rank guardians lower than
they have it here in favor of bumping up
like infinity ORS Oh Guardians the first
guardians is participation possible yeah
yeah because I totally forgot about back
if I were that like no that should be my
five but there's a no-win scenario when
you're ranking Marvel movie yeah
especially when there's so many now that
there are almost twenty there will be
twenty when a man 2 comes out and like
at that point it's like you're gonna
just have to leave some stuff out
the list that you love and you're gonna
have to rank some things places you
don't want to rank as Guardians one is
perfect to me I'd probably knock out
Iron Man for guardians and one that also
comes into the ideas of where you're
drawing the list from I can understand
you going but Iron Man started at all
it's like I I was a little surprised the
first Avengers was higher up than
infinity war but then I was like well
there is no infinity war if we don't get
the first Avengers and the first
Avengers you know even if they've done
crazier things since then it's still
such a moment yeah a context and it's
also a complete movie it's not a
cliffhanger of an ending it also has a
heroic vibe and triumph to it the spirit
of it there are less things about that
movie that are justified by like well
there's so many characters it has to be
like that like I feel like Infinity Ward
even if that's not a bad thing it does
have that Avengers you the first one you
could watch without having to watch the
other like infinity war greatly depends
on a strong following
or at least a five or six to catch you
once I've met people that haven't been
following all them just like really
confused one of the effects takes would
be so much lower oh yeah they've just
not spent the time yeah exactly
whereas where's the first Avengers there
are people who go watch setting and
understand what's going on totally this
isn't impossible is to satisfy this guy
had a little more enthusiasm ordinary it
convinced me that infinity war belongs
at number seven or eight oh yeah the
voice of passion in this guy and maybe
that's it maybe they couldn't agree on
anything so well you seem like the most
neutral person well guys what are your
how would you rank your top 10 favorite
Marvel films put it down below and the
comment boxes would love to see what
that is you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
I'll get notified every time one of our
videos is up and make sure to download
the Vikings war of clans app today
people 200 extra gold absolutely link in
the description box we know other
youtubers who have partnered up with
this app as well there's a reason why do
it